c'est la nouvelle de la journée enrico
bienvenus quand un athlète qui en plus
est un ancien joueur des canadiens
acceptent de se lancer en politique
vous avez presque automatiquement un
candidat vedette
parce que honnêtement qui n'aiment pas
les athlètes
[Musique]
j'ai gagné également des championnats
les six ados rebelles le gagnant
exactement le genre d'image que les
chefs veulent coller à leurs formations
politiques et les libéraux ne sont pas
les seuls aujourd'hui je décide de
plonger la caq annoncé la candidature de
l'ancienne médaillée olympique en
patinage de vitesse
isabelle charest dans le comté de brome
missisquoi ont fédérales les
conservateurs ont facilement gagné leur
pari en misant sur richard martel
l'ancien entraîneur des saguenéens de
chicoutimi lors de la paire ciel dans
chicoutimi le fjord des sportifs qui
font le saut en politique il y en a ici
mais il y en a aussi partout dans le
monde
saviez vous que le légendaire pelé a été
ministre brésilien des sports dans les
années 90 aux philippines le boxeur
manny pacquiao a remporté deux fois les
élections ici au québec ou au canada les
sportifs qui gagnent leur sélection
ont-ils un rôle clé au sein du
gouvernement
là le seul exemple qui vient rapidement
en tête c'est ken dryden
il a été ministre fédéral du
développement social sous paul martin un
ministère qui dépassait largement sont
passés de gardien vedette des canadiens
de montréal mais en politique comme dans
le sport pour gagner il faut aussi être
dans le bon camp un exemple la vie smith
un ancien joueur de football qui comme
président a littéralement sauvé la
franchise des alouettes de montréal un
personnage aimé crédible et très connu
mais quand monsieur smit s'est présenté
pour les conservateurs dans un comté
montréalais et les il a longé la
poussière il a fini troisième lors des
élections fédérales de 2011
la limite est aujourd'hui sénateur car
au canada les sportifs qui font le saut
en politique
atterré surtout au sénat fraîchement
reach d'ainsi green jacques demers et
plus récemment
chantal petitclerc